we've been talking quite a bit about
this water crisis in Flint Michigan
outrageous water crisis that may
actually be criminal in nature led in
the water after the source for the
town's water was switched to the Flint
River has made has potentially poisoned
up to eight thousand children so I was
thrilled to hear that the Michigan
Senate came together and they were able
to push a bill through which does
absolutely nothing about the water
crisis in Flint but instead bans anal
sex so-called sodomy ban it is even more
insane because Michigan already has a
sodomy ban and obviously these bans are
ridiculous because the 2003 Supreme
Court case of Lawrence v Texas declares
sodomy bans are unconstitutional in all
states so let me say this as concisely
as possible Louis instead of helping the
people being poisoned by their own water
as a result of a government decision to
save some money Michigan Republicans are
spending time and money to uphold a
sodomy ban that number one already
exists a number two is impossible to
enforce an unconstitutional what a great
use of time from our friends the
Republicans in Michigan huh I think the
saddest part about this is probably the
majority of their constituents maybe not
constituents maybe just their supporters
okay probably have no idea that this is
even happening maybe not and I just I
just don't understand who gets up in the
face of a water crisis like this and
says this is this is important we need
to focus on this it takes an anal yeah
and I'm gonna talk on the bonus show
about Obama's clean water proposal yes
you know at a federal level would help
address what's going on over there you
might wonder how they even passed such a
ridiculous bill this might not shock you
they attached it to an animal rights
bill which was trying to keep pets out
of the hands of animal abusers and they
put in a section about bestiality and
then they said two adults having anal
sex is basically like abusing an animal
and the language specifically is a
person who commits the abominable and
detestable crime against nature sodomy
either with mankind or with any animal
is guilty of a felony punishable by
imprisonment for not more than 50 or 15
years politics at its worst
what is more abominable and detestable
anal sex between consult the consenting
adults or subjecting an entire community
to toxic water to save a few bucks you
decide Lewis I'm glad they have their
priorities straight also 10 children
died as a result of that right yeah I'm
an anal Louis ten children died from
water yes so I think we don't really
need to comment any more on that I think
we know which one is more detestable
yeah basically speaks for itself
absolutely disgusting